[Music]
You have to uh pay
attention
to how much yin you do. Okay?
So, for example, I'll slow it down.
Okay? So, we're
here. Boom.
He
counters. I come in. And now what you
guys are doing is there's still some
weight there. Okay? And you take it all
off so that you can enter. And what that
does is it stops his
head. And that is him assisting you,
okay? Because no real person's going to
do that. So you have to keep the head in
its tilt. Okay?
It's not it's not about speed. It's just
about uh not stopping that there.
Okay. I just I just don't stop the the
control as I'm whatever I'm touching is
still affecting the kazushi. Okay. And
it's different every time to be
honest. Okay.
That was not
it. Just
keep moving.
Okay, try it again.
You see you James, please.
James. Okay. So, once when you get here,
right? You got you you got him here and
there's the lean. You're getting him
leaning.
Okay. When you go to the wrist, you're
going to go around the shoulder. Do you
see that? And now he's Now he's yin. You
went
yin. You the center that you're moving
here. You keep
moving with the same grounding
technique that he's pushing. You're
here. Okay. Right? You just ground that
energy and then you're moving. You're
still grounding it when you move. Do do
you understand?
You're walking normal is part of the
problem. You're like, I can't take that
step. So, let me move that and now I can
take the step. Okay.
Have the other hand ready because as he
begins to fall, that's where this hand
loses its
integrity. So have it ready. A lot of
you don't have it ready. You're here and
you need that pause to bring it into
position. But on the first video, you
already have that
trap. So as you're moving, it's
there. Okay.
just catches it. Don't stop and pull it.
Continue with the kazushi and the hand
will be there. Okay, try it again.
Discovery learning. Get the echo your
wrist right there. Okay. Got it. Hold
it. Hold it again. Really like your life
depends on
it. Okay. It's not the control point you
think it is. So learn that for yourself.
You'll do it with one hand. You went two
hands. It's not the technique, but it
doesn't matter. Okay. So yank it like
you mean it. Right hook to the face.
Okay. You'll have the wrist. Okay. And
I'll be here. Okay. Got it. Got it. Got
it.
Okay. Then we'll do the other one.
You'll have his elbow. He's just
straight. Nope. Just straight. Okay. He
goes. Then we'll have him tilted like
the technique. He
goes, "Okay, discovery learning. Go."
Okay. So, what I was saying was it's not
that I go here and I try to get there
really fast. It's just that I'm keeping
the control
points that keep his head moving on that
tilt. Just keep that head moving on the
tilt.
That's all I'm doing.
Then you put the trap
in. You
see? Do you see that? Okay. So, we've
done that drill before, right? Just
focus on the elbow. But you have to be
careful because the tilt is the spiral
rotation. It's not you're here and
you're pushing him away. Do do you get
that? You're you're you're tilting him
into the kazushi pattern.
Sorry. So he has to go around you. Boom.
This way.
which means you have to enter with the
turn.
Okay? So, you're doing all that and all
that gets easier as you control the
wrist, but you should not be dependent
on the wrist. Okay?
Try.